merci de faire la paix on t'aime on a
nice on attend même nom
ça
serra
[Applaudissements]
vincent mc doom est avec nous ce soir
sonne beaucoup et c'est vrai que
personne n'a oublié communiqué comment
il vous a découvert ça restera je monte
dans le livre des français un grand
grand moment c'était la première ferme
on a découvert un personnage hors norme
alors ce qu'on ne sait pas où on va on
est dans un instant c'est qu'au départ
vincent mcdoom samnick des pantalons
tout à fait mais oui ou alors pourquoi
vous êtes passé de ce style
vestimentaire
ob à celui de ba de filles une robe ça
s'est passé en fait dans la ferme en
fête et c'est cette anecdote assez
intéressant dans la femme nous avons
nous avons eu des pluies pour boire de
l'eau met en joue depuis été contaminés
et j'ai pas eu le temps de habib de
m'habiller et jégu en pull qui était
très longue
en fait et je me une paire de talons je
traversé les champs voilée on est en
faisant ça à vos images petite gastro
oui oui oui une petite gastro mais tout
le monde moi en particulier je traverse
et le chant et cette image a fait le
tour de france en fait et ça fait
augmenter leurs 10 matchs en fait de
deux millions de tonnes
on a les images on lire dans l'outaouais
la ferme célébrités bien sûr top 10
[Musique]
moi je vous le dis ça va les changer
mais
ouais
cette agence est à la fois viril voix
féminine au moins tu es complet un
talent mais ce qui offre saas est
mignonne comme ça tranquille car je te
dis que laisse moi tranquille
hugh jackman a investi dans ce vote
sinon mais toi tu prends tout pout tous
gbagbo
j'ai l'impression que même à des jeux
lâchés
[Musique]
l'acteur
révolution parce que la rencontre avant
des animaux ce qu'il y avait vraiment
des animaux c'était magnifique oui
heureusement et a eu des animaux parce
qu et les relations entre et humain
n'est pas facile non et les animaux
étaient là pour apaiser en fait les
essais n'étaient pas forcément les
animaux qui sentait le plus mauvais non
mais je peux me perrin ce qu'ils
voulaient tish moutet alors c'est pas ça
les garçons ont regagné leurs chambres
les filles ont eu leurs champs mais
malheureusement quand on est entre nous
et il faisait toujours 19 salles et non
je suis né malheureusement qu'est ce qui
se passe et il faisait trop froid
c'était un mois d'avril et nos étés trop
foin sur le plus bas des animaux
le plupart des candidats ne prenez pas
une bûche pendant deux semaines ça
commence à une personne qui ne me
prenait pas des 12 qui s'est aspergée
derrière tout ça c'était mass moca
massimo gargia moi je les ai eus après
dans la ferme célébrités en afrique
j'ai deux trois années je vois
contrainte et non je me souviens mois
d'une relation très forte que vous avez
eue avec faut le dire avec une vache
oui en affaires on a des images c'est la
moitié a été regardé par mois je vous le
dis ça va les changer
mais à ce stade de jeu
pourquoi moi il
[Musique]
un train de vie bien
donnez moi il répond sans fin d'un jeu
[Applaudissements]
c'est voter
et célèbres
qu'est ce que tu fais là
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
m
je fais pipi d'un an une bouée de lavage
et rappelez-vous la baronne vers 7
heures avec l'autruche mais la parole
c'était le deuxième on va pas juste les
avions c'était un carton alors que
c'était 6 millions 900 mille en moyenne
saison 2 5 millions 800 mille et ça
c'était en 2005 et en 2010 avec la ferme
célébrités en afrique serait donc la
saison 3 à 3 millions 700 mille alors la
femme soit fixe pas vous mentir ça a été
un désastre
ah oui bah oui vous n'ayez pourquoi
quand on a lancé cette émission j'ai
l'ablation de l'année avec jean pierre
foucault
on est donc vendu une émission familiale
qui se passait en afrique et en effet
des photos avec la savate jaune
forcément mes animaux sauvages les lions
et rhinocéros les hiérarques terre bon
quand on est arrivé sur le tournage
était pas les années vous n'avez pas dit
la vérité il y avait il y avait une pop
girafe
y avait il y avait une espèce de marque
était la mare aux crocodiles et débit
comme ça la police
c'était la dépression de taille et
surtout en afrique un coup d'état
on a fait alors venir et surtout en
afrique du sud que je ne savais pas
c'est que c'est ouvert ça ressemble à la
normandie et oui quand on lance cette
option dans ses missions premiers
lancements ont fait 7 millions pour la
première c'était un carton après on fait
la semaine de quotidienne voilà et on
fait la deuxième on passe de 7 millions
à 3 millions
voilà donc on est convoqué à tf1 parce
qu'à l'époque et tf1 comme on l'a dit
avec barrières commencent à baisser des
chiffres ont été convoqués et là le
patron de l'époque ne me convoque et
donc n des mollahs la patronne de
l'époque et lui dit est ce que quelqu'un
peut me dire pourquoi j'ai ce programme
21 millions d'euros que j'aurais pu
faire juste à côté à thoiry ça a été un
désastre on n'a jamais vu un lyon jamais
de rien il y avait un rien rien on avait
des candidats qui se taper dessus
j'espère poignardé ça a été un désastre
a vécu un enfer avec toutefois je vous
dis c'est pas un bon souvenir
et puis alors il y avait il ya vait
vendetta qui et qui déjà avait mis au
jour qui avait déjà
j'avais déjà mis au goût du jour le
delormeau moderne bogossitude dites est
exact c'est moi chef fait muet comme une
carpe
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
tu es plus beau faire la grève tu es le
plus grand chanteur du monde cette fois
s'attaque un jeune de 20 ans est ce que
tu penses que mickaël vendetta que fait
de longues missions phacochères attend
est ce qu on parle pas comme ça monsieur
à mickaël vendetta donc un peu de
respect c'est nous plaît c'est fou je
suis quelqu'un à côté je suis à côté
d'un grand monsieur
elle est à malibu oh là là ça allait
de voir cette haine gratuite c'est toute
cette méchanceté que j'ai
être mickaël vendetta la ferme à c'est
une horreur c'est une horreur vraiment
d'accord tous les réseaux sociaux on va
demander de le recadrer en direct ce
mythe est tellement insupportable et je
vis de cette phrase affreux j'avais dit
mieux vaut être un has been qu'un never
been
donc après la chaîne avait reproché
d'avoir fait au final il a gagné la
femme c'est au final oui alors ça fait
partie des débats des gagnon qu'on
aurait préféré ne pas avoir mais ça
prouve bien que c'est pas nous qui
votons voyez us à la star aux hommes il
faut quand même dire que c'est un rendu
extrêmement populaire gens ont le temps
et met tout de suite et que ça a fait
avancer les gens ont adhéré tout de
suite parce qu en fait l'histoire
c'était pascal olmeta et moi même ces
deux entités beau différents et
finalement le public a vu la naissance
d'une amitié entre deux hommes que
normalement qui n'auraient pas jamais
fait également sa c'était oui oui
toujours
toujours à l'époque ça fait jusqu'à 11
millions de tonnes
c'était l'émission qui a fait les
palettes grande score dodine incroyable
incroyable ça reste inconscient ailleurs
évidemment pour vous tiens bon souvenir
au final incroyable oui mais c'était pas
trop ne s'est pas trop difficile quand
même parfois pour moi la naissance de
notre amitié et pascal et moi c'est
parce qu'elle moi je regrettais dans
l'avion un partant là bas à vierzon et
je disais j'ai regretté de vouloir faire
cette émission et lui il m'a dit je suis
persuadé qu'ils vont essayer de me
piéger avec des choses qui est un peu
féminin si toi tu le fais moi je ferai
les choses de plus dur et toi tu es
c'est comme ça en amitié mais ça vous a
rendu extrêmement sympathique en plus il
fallait les gens vous savez encore plus
sympathique
oui effectivement va redemander sur la
télé réalité il affirme imposé c'est la
même chose tout mais pas contre ce que
je trouve ces sept on m'a demandé de
faire d'autres émissions de télé réalité
mais c'est pas ça que je voulais faire
les choses on me demande d'être nounou
dans les anges ont fait des choses comme
ça je pensais venir
la départementalisation comme ça et
c'est pas ça que je voulais faire en
fait 20 je voulais sorte présenté au
peps
je suis une célébrité sortez moi de là
où vous êtes pas parce qu'ils ont c'est
qu'ils cherchent à sebha vraiment ils
vous ont pas assez intéressant que tu
poses la question parce que beaucoup des
gens me disent eh ben c'est le moment de
recommencer avec une ambition de
célébrer les paniers ici que je tout qui
est dommage
en fait avec le cast et chaque fois on
essaie de faire des casses et on essaie
de tout les personnes qui sont
rassemblés à voir ces dommages ne pas
reprendre certaines personnes qui ont
fait le beau jude et certaines émissions
et remet au goût de jouer et ça pourrait
le rappeler en fait vous ont pas plus
pour ceux qui lisent ou non on m'a
jamais apprises et peut-être que j'ai
passé mes amis c'est pas c'est pas une
émission de télé réalité comme les
téléréalités craquelé shirt mais la
décontraction
[Rires]
je ne suis pas du pas de la partie vous
avez fait une de ses initiales c'est la
papesse des défaites des candidats de
télé réalité
ah bon
[Rires]
une émission comme ça je trouve ça
intéressant de revenir tout va aller
vraie émission le vrai base des
émissions de téléréalité mais ces
émissions de real télé réalité j'ai
souffert des bosses pour boss salvatore
il est rejoint par contre c'est que vous
êtes un candidat extrêmement touchant
effectivement aujourd'hui il y en a il y
en a beaucoup des très touchant mais des
comme vous il y en a pas beaucoup
il y en a pas non non non non moi je
dirais que cette visite mais je dirais
je dirais quelque chose avant à l'époque
on nous on faisait la fin c'était
beaucoup plus bucolique beaucoup plus
honnête on fait ça avant nous ne s'était
pas calculer ça et on faisait de l'image
avec tu as fais là
le premier loft tu sais exactement bien
sûr j'aimerais qu'on remercie bien sûr
manaudou et réconfort
[Applaudissements]